alors que dimanche l'entrée dans les
musées sera gratuite
inauguration aujourd'hui à strasbourg
d'un nouveau temple de l'art moderne et
contemporain
un bâtiment où il est extrêmement pur
qui devra accueillir des expositions
temporaires ou des oeuvres de grande
qualité picasso kandinsky ou encore
clint reportage antoine cormery
jean-pierre plaster un cheval pour
figure de proue et dément cher qui
évoque par grands paquebots sous la
plume de l'architecte adrien fainsilber
à qui l'on doit déjà la cité des
sciences de la villette
voici le dernier né des grands musées
français des années qu'on attendait ça à
strasbourg où la très riche collection
du xxème siècle n'avait jusqu'à lors
jamais réussi à faire son trou
aujourd'hui on s'y emploie coups de
perceuse sous l'oeil avisé d'un
conservateur décaler légèrement sur le
préfet car avant l'ouverture
tout se joue au cm on éprouve avoir
enfin après tant d'années des tableaux
accrochés ici on est content ce sens on
souffre on n'y croyait plus c'est vrai
c'est un énorme travail de fond les gens
ne s'en rendent pas compte
depuis ce qu'on a à faire en amour on a
fait sur deux ans une énorme campagne de
restauration de fabrication de cadres et
bon c'est la récompense un canton les
ovations
et voilà le travail 700 oeuvres de la
fin du 19ème à nos jours une sorte de
condensé d'orsay et de beaubourg les
impressionnistes sont en bonne place aux
côtés de clint kandinsky et harpe
l'enfant du pays mais la vocation du
musée est aussi de faire connaître le
travail des artistes d'aujourd'hui avec
pour ambassadeur buren toroni lavier
morellet je peux juger aujourd'hui de là
où je suis c'est à dire comme ministre
de l'intérêt de ce projet de
l'importance qu'il ya à voir en province
des expositions de grande qualité et
face aux grandes institutions de
l'allemagne ou de la suisse voisine
strasbourg grâce aux 235 millions de
francs injectés dans le projet peut
maintenant on s'afficher avec le sourire
comme une des places européennes
importantes pour l'art contemporain